hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mont und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
moin und ich bin Natalie Strauss
Radiomoderatorin und ein riesiger True
Crime Fan zusammen mit meinem
geschätzten Gesprächspartner Sprecher
und Moderator und Mirko Kasimir werden
wir auch heute einen Kriminalfall
besprechen der uns beide nicht loslässt
und schon ziemlich lange ein Cold Case
ist hallo Natalie schön dich zu sehen
du hast Recht denn das ist einer unser
Fälle die wohl am weitesten zurückliegen
denn dieses Verbrechen führt uns mehr
als 3000 Jahren die Vergangenheit zurück
nämlich ins Ägypten des Jahres 1154 vor
unserer Zeitrechnung es ist ein Fall in
dem ein toter Mund aus dem Jenseits
heraus Anklage erhebt und es ist ein
Fall der zeigt dass politische Morde
keine Erfindung der Neuzeit sind
wir begeben uns 3000 Jahre zurück und
befinden uns in der Regenten Metropole
Luxor am Nil der sonst eigentlich
lebensspendende Fluss der mit seinen
zyklischen Überschwemmungen für die
Fruchtbarkeit der landwirtschaftlich
genutzten Böden des gewaltigen Reiches
sorgt stottert seit einigen Jahren das
Klima ist unsteht die Ernten fallen
nicht zu üppig wie gewohnt aus hier und
da herrscht Mangel viele Menschen müssen
hungern aber das hindert den 65-Jährigen
Herrscher über Ägypten Ramses den
dritten nicht daran weiter viele
kostspielige gebautätigkeiten zu
betreiben größer mächtiger und schöner
das ist was ein Pharao zu erschaffen hat
um den Sonnengott Armut zu ehren
irdische Investitionen für himmlischen
Ruhm die vier Manpower und Ressourcen
verschlingen die allermeisten Handwerker
und Arbeiter werden in Naturalien
entlohnt das heißt Sie bekommen Getreide
und Feldfrüchte um damit ihre Familien
zu ernähren oder Tauschhandel zu
betreiben doch die Lieferungen stocken
dem gottesgleichen Pharao und König ist
das egal und die Priesterschaft
empfiehlt sogar noch mehr Opfergaben an
den Sonnengott und die anderen
nebengötter dazu reichen
wenn man nachschlägt findet man schnell
ein paar Infos zu Ramses dem dritten
erst natürlich Sprosse einer Dynastie in
dem Fall der 20 oder auch neues Reich
genannt
1154 vor unserer Zeit ist Ramses der
dritte schon in seinem 32 regierungsjahr
man würde sagen ein erfahrener
Staatsmann und Herrscher ein Herrscher
übrigens der auch viele Kriege geführt
hat und das wenn man den Inschriften
glauben mag auch immer ziemlich am
vorderster Freund
berühmt sind seine Kämpfe gegen die
Seevölker aus dem Mittelmeerraum die mit
ihren Schiffen den nilfluss
aufwärtssiegelten und eine echte Gefahr
für den ägyptischen Staat darstellten
Ramses der dritte sitzt also ziemlich
fest und geachtet im Sattel oder eben
auf dem Thron mit der mächtigen
Priesterschaft kommt der gut aus die
wichtigen Feste werden zelebriert und
die Abgaben an die Tempel sprudeln
fröhlich ein großer Streik der Arbeiter
auf einer seiner Großbaustellen
beschäftigt ihn deshalb nicht sonderlich
der Wache und Militärapparat nimmt sich
der aufwiedler an und dennoch Humor des
nicht nur im Volk sondern auch in der
eigenen Klasse in der Kaste der
herrschenden denn wie alle Pharaonen
oder Könige und Königinnen vor ihm sorgt
sich der Herrscher um seine Nachfolge
umso mehr als das Ramses weiß dass er
nicht mehr allzu lange zu leben hat eine
fortgeschrittene Arteriosklerose macht
ihm schwer zu schaffen
körperliche Anstrengungen selbst bis hin
zum simplen Treppensteigen strengen ihn
bisweilen schmerzhaft an sein Herz
brennt
Arteriosklerose ist eine Gefäßkrankheit
damals wie heute übrigens weit
verbreitet sie zeigt sich maßgeblich
darin dass Blutgefäße nach und nach mit
sogenannten Plugs zugesetzt werden die
einerseits dem Blut Durchfluss behindern
was zu Sauerstoffmangel führt außerdem
kann es den Blutdruck katastrophal
erhöhen zudem noch die Gefäßwände
brüchig machen verstopfen solche Gefäße
oder Arterien gerade in der Nähe eines
Herzkranzgefäßes völlig dann droht
natürlich der Infarkt heute wissen wir
dass diese Erkrankung durch falsche zu
fettreiche Ernährung zu wenig Bewegung
Alkoholmissbrauch und das Rauchen
befeuert wird was für einen hohen wenn
man weiß wie das Volk meist hungert hat
ja damals galt es einfach nur als ein
Zeichen der Schwäche des Herrschers
zurück zur Ramses Nachfolgern Ramses hat
wie alle Herrscher zu der Zeit mehrere
Frauen die alle zusammen in einem Harem
Leben der Harem befindet sich ebenfalls
im Palast und ist im Prinzip das private
zu Hause des fahrero wo er intim sein
kann meist übernachtet Ramses hier und
kommt durchaus den Pflichten eines
Ehemanns und Liebhabers nach der Harem
ist ein Hofstaat im Hofstaat aus der
Forschung weiß man dass Ramses eine
Hauptfrau hatte die große königliche
Gemahlin Isetta hemjard nennen wir sie
in Kurzform einfach
schon in jungen Jahren mindestens zwei
Söhne Raum sitzt den vierten und Ramses
den sechsten zum Zeitpunkt unserer
Geschichte ist zumindest einer der
beiden Söhne als Prinz schon ein
gestandener Mann Rams ist der 4 ist
knapp 40 verheiratet und begleitet hohe
militärische und politische Ämter
Sache ist also geritzt so scheint es nur
hat der Herrscher eine seiner
Nebenfrauen zwar inoffiziell aber
ebenfalls zur großen königlichen
Gemahlin gemacht
wird am Hof sicher nicht so genannt
verfügt jedoch über die entsprechenden
Privilegien und hat eben auch Einfluss
im politischen und familiären Sinne auch
Tier hat einen Sohn er wird später
pentaway ja genannt er ist ungefähr 20
Jahre alt militärisch ausgebildet und
scheint ein recht schlauer Kopf zu sein
auch ist hier deutlich jünger als die
Königs Gemahlin iset und sieht sich noch
lange nicht am Ende der Karriereleiter
angekommen man sollte sich so einen
Haaren nicht wie in einem Sandalen Film
oder im Märchen vorstellen stellte sich
eher wie eine geräumige Villa vor mit
verschiedenen Wohnungen einer
Nachbarschaft eigener Verwaltung Hotel
und eventuell auch Modellbetrieb es gab
dort neben den Frauen auch deren Kinder
in verschiedenen Altersstufen viele
waren auch schon wieder mit dem Partner
und Partnerinnen also da ist eine Menge
los auch eine Menge Service und
Wachpersonal wurde beschäftigt es ist
schlicht der Hofstaat die Frauen waren
immer am Ohr des Regenten und konnten so
auch die Politik beeinflussen Intrigen
waren also ganz sicher an der
Tagesordnung und nun ist da dieser
aufstrebende Nebenfrau Tier und ihr Sohn
die ganz genau die Zeichen der Zeit
lesen können den Frauen war allen klar
das ramsis der dritte schwer krank sein
muss denn er kam vermutlich auch seiner
sexuellen Pflicht nicht mehr so richtig
nach wenn schon Treppensteigen schwer
fällt wie sieht's denn mit Sex aus
Tier spürt dass nicht mehr viel Zeit
bleibt ihren Sohn als Nachfolger des
Pharao Spiel zu bringen
pintereyer ist übrigens nicht der
richtige Name ihres Sohnes den kennen
wir nicht pintereier heißt eigentlich
nur der der jenen anderen Namen trug
weshalb er so genannt wird das erfahren
wir noch
Mirko wie geht es weiter da ist nun TS
Rivalin die offizielle Königs Gemahlin
isets mit ihren beiden prinzensöhnen die
fertig ausgebildet und im startgut
vernetzt und reibungslos die Geschäfte
übernehmen werden wenn der Herrscher ins
Jenseits reisen wird hier hat aber sehr
wohl den Finger am Puls des einfachen
Volkes und spürt dass der Unmut über
Hunger und Ausbeutung dort gewaltig ist
zudem pflegt sie Verbindungen ins
Militär und ist im niederen Hofstaat
ziemlich angesehen sie verkehrt mit den
hofdienern des Pharaos wie zum Beispiel
mit einem namens message Suche und
Beamten wie dem Speisekammer Vorsteher
bei bekamen
Tier weiß genau einen Pharao stürzt man
nicht allein man braucht Verbündete sie
muss den Staat stürzen den ramsis der
dritte repräsentiert
ihr fragt euch vielleicht woher wir das
alles wissen also es gibt im Ägyptischen
Museum in Turin einem Papyrus der bis
ins Detail beschreibt wie eine weltliche
Gerichtsverhandlung im Jahr 1154 vor
unserer Zeit abläuft in dieser
Gerichtsverhandlung geht es um den mords
am gottgleichen Pharao Ramses den
dritten interessant ist dass der Tote
Pharao selbst die Mörder beim weltlichen
Gericht angeklagt haben soll wie das im
Einzelnen geschehen soll ist mir bis
heute ziemlich unklar aber andere Zeiten
andere Sitten wichtig ist aber dass wir
dadurch die Namen der Verschwörer kennen
und einen möglichen Ablauf rekonstrieren
können es kommt nämlich hinzu dass auch
die Mumie von Rahmen des dritten in den
Sammlungen Kairos existiert man hat
diese nur noch einmal genauer unter die
Lupe genommen also nicht unter die Lupe
sondern unter einen hochmodernen
Computertomographen
das ist alles vor knapp zehn Jahren
geschehen die nötiger Carsten Pusch und
der Paleo Pathologe Albert Zink die auch
schon den eiszeitjäger Ötzi untersuchten
stellten bei dem bildgebenden Verfahren
fest der Pharao hat unter der Halsbinde
einen 7 cm langen Schnitt der durch alle
Gefäße die Luft und Speiseröhre bis zur
Wirbelsäule den Hals durchtrennte das
überlebt natürlich niemand Rahmen ist
der dritte muss getötet worden sein
übrigens wurde bei dieser
Computertomographie auch festgestellt
dass der Herrscher besagte schwere
Arteriosklerose hatte und ein Detail für
den Forschern ebenfalls auf in der Wunde
am Hals der Mumie liegt ein kleines
Horus Amulett verborgen ein Amulett das
eine Heilung im Jenseits bewirken soll
aber wer war es die Intrigen werden
gesponnen
Tier und ihr Sohn entscheiden sich zu
handeln im Frühjahr 1154 vor unserer
Zeit werden viele Feste zu Ehren der
Götter des Flusses und des Pharao
vorbereitet und ist ziemlich geschäftig
am Hof am Palast gehen viele Menschen
ein und aus es gibt viel zu organisieren
so fällt es nicht weiter auf dass die
Nebenfrau Thiel und ihr Sohn sehr viel
kommunizieren es geht nicht mehr nur um
Mord es soll ein Staatsstreich werden
die Streiks auf den Baustellen nehmen zu
Teile des Militär stehen nach
Landverlusten dem König und seiner
Führung kritisch gegenüber Beamte und
Bedienstete am Hof die bisher in den
Beförderungen übergangen wurden sehen in
einem Wechsel der Administration meine
große Chance aber wie einen
gottesgleichen töten wie wird Amun Reh
der Sonnengott reagieren und wie die
anderen Götter um sicherzugehen dass
Pharao und Gott voneinander getrennt
werden muss ein Zauber hier und dieser
Zauber ist niedergeschrieben auf Papyrus
liegt in der Bibliothek des Palastes und
wird unter strenger Obhut der
Priesterschaft verwahrt hier und Forst
machen es möglich dass Tier und ihre
Mitverschwörer an den wichtigen
Zauberspruch gelangen
in Kombination mit kleinen
wachsabbildungen des Herrschers kann der
altägyptische Voodoo seine Kraft
entfalten nachdem dieser er mystische
Teil erledigt ist schreitet die Gruppe
zur Tat
Rams ist der dritte ist jeden Tag in
seinem Haare danach ließe sich jede Öl
Sand und Wasseruhr Stellen im Harem sind
die Leibwächter außen vor der Regent
wähnt sich in seiner Geliebten
Großfamilie sicher was soll da schon
passieren
genießt den Respekt und Liebreiz
dutzender wunderschöner und mächtiger
Frauen die Liebe seiner unzähligen Söhne
und Prinzen er ist der unumstrittene
Patriarch im Hause Luxor
tja da hat er sich gehörig geirrt und
viel zu sicher gefühlt als ich Paleo
Pathologe Albert Zink die Mumie nämlich
im CT genauer anschaut stellt er
nebenbei fest dass Teile eines
Vorderfußes von Ramses vor seinem Tod
abgetrennt wurden die Sache sieht so aus
als hätte jemand mit einer Axt den
großen Zeh abgetrennt geht man davon aus
dass der Pharao nicht selbst Holz hat
und auch im Krieg keine solche
Verletzung erlitten hat was sicherlich
Erwähnung gefunden hätte dann deutet
alles auf einen heftigen Kampf hin bei
dem wild um sich geschlagen wurde ein
Indiz ist auch dass die Wunde nicht
verheilt aussieht aber Mirko ein 65
jähriger kranker Mann kämpft um sein
Leben wie kann die Tat abgelaufen sein
vielleicht folgendermaßen
Hofdiener messetsuche informiert den
speisekammervorsteher der wiederum
Zutritt zum Haaren hat dass der Regent
auf dem Weg ist und Alt weiter um das
eingeschworene Militär und weitere
umsturzler zu aktivieren der Herrscher
betritt wenig später seinen Haaren
doch er kommt nicht weit hinter den
schweren Toren warten schon Tier und ihr
Sohn auf Ramses der ist anfangs noch
hoch erfreut seine heimliche zweite
Hauptfrau zu sehen aber irgendetwas
stimmt nicht mit ihr und dann wird er
schon von hinten und um den Hals gepackt
und niedergerissen am Arm Schmuck
erkennt er das ist die starken Arme
seines Sohnes sind dann schreitet auch
Tier auf ihn zu in der Hand eine
Streitaxt Ramses fragt sich wohl noch wo
sie diese wohl her hat und tritt nach
seiner völlig veränderten geliebten er
wird damit zwar den tödlichen Schlag der
Axt ab die fährt ihm aber dennoch in den
Fuß er schreit auf und kann sich fast
den Armen seines Sohnes entwinden Tier
schlägt erneut mit der Waffe zu verfehlt
ihn aber ein weiteres Mal
ramsisch schreit vor Wut und Angst sein
Herz rast und seine Kraft schwindet nun
spürt er die kühle Klinge an seinem Hals
und dann
nichts mehr
das klingt nach ganz schön viel Lärm und
weniger nach einem heimlichen Mord im
stillen Kämmerlein das ist nicht
wirklich gut für die umstürzer gelaufen
das Geschrei des angegriffenen Königs
lässt sehr schnell auch die anderen
Frauen und Bewohner des harams zum
Tatort heilen als man den Herrscher im
Blut liegen sah muss allen klar gewesen
sein was ihr vorgefallen sein muss die
Verschwörerin und ihr Sohn werden
entwaffnet und festgenommen die Wachen
führen das mörderpärchen ab in diesem
Moment verliert auch der Sohn Thies
einen wichtigen Namen und wird ab nun
nur noch genannt sein richtiger Name
soll von nun an weder ausgesprochen noch
an ihn erinnert werden das erinnert mich
ein bisschen an Harry Potter und der
dessen Namen nicht genannt werden darf
schnell sind auch die anderen
Verschwörer gefasst hi bekamen dessen
eigentlicher Name auch durch seine Taten
gelöscht wurde und unzählige weitere
Beamte und Bedienstete den Behörden ist
klar hier sollte das Volk aufgewiegelt
und dann mit militärischer Macht der
Umsturz herbeigeführt werden
aber die Bombe zündete nur schwach und
verbrannte nur die die mit dem Feuer
spielten
Mirko wie reagiert der legitime
Thronfolger auf diesen Verrat naja Rams
ist der vierte der Sohn des Toten
Herrschers ist voller Zorn wie konnten
sich die Attentäter nur in einer noch so
winzig kleinen Chance eines Sieges Venen
Amon Reh hat seine schützende Hand über
das Reich nun sein Reich am Nil gehalten
das Volk darf aber noch nicht erfahren
was geschehen ist ein Mord an einem
gottesgleichen ist undenkbar Rams ist
berät sich mit seiner Mutter iset und
der Priesterschaft die bestätigt dass
der Herrscher eigentlich nur schläft und
an seiner schweren Krankheit leidet doch
erlebt ganz sicher man kommt überein die
anstehenden Feste zu feiern und dann den
natürlichen Tod des Herrschers
auszurufen er Rams ist der vierte wird
aber ob der aktuellen Verfassung seines
Vaters schon jetzt die Geschäfte
übernehmen doch ohne Krone und Insignien
aber mit voller Unterstützung des
Staatsapparates
in seiner königlichen Mutter die
Priester bestätigen noch am selben Tag
dass der todkranke Herrscher die
Verschwörerbande des Mordversuchs
anklagt es soll ein Verfahren geben wie
es luxors Machtzirkel noch nicht gesehen
hat auch als Warnung an all jene die
ähnliches planen mögen
eine Warnung die so gut dokumentiert
worden ist dass sogar wir 3000 Jahre
später alles nachlesen können auf dem
Papyrus der im Ägyptischen Museum in
Turin liegt sind dieses
Gerichtsverfahren und die Urteile
verzeichnet vielleicht war es auch eine
Art Präzedenzfall und man hatte damit
eine mögliche Vorgehensweise bei
ähnlichen vorkommen müssen durch die
CT-Untersuchung wurde nun klar dass der
Papyrus nicht von einer Legende
berichtet sondern in Anbetracht der
tatsächlichen tödlichen Verletzung an
Ramses Körper von Tatsachen eine der
ersten gut überlieferten true
crime-storys und die liefert einiges
Liebe macht Sex geheime Zauber und
Vertuschung wie ging es nach dem Prozess
mit dem Beteiligten weiter
so richtig lange hat man nicht gefackert
die involvierten Beamten Hofdiener und
Militärs verloren ihren Namen und
etwaige Kartuschen in Inschriften und
Chroniken sie wurden quasi ausgelöscht
danach hat man sie schlicht umgebracht
und verbrannt vielleicht auch bei
lebendigem Leiber auf jeden Fall ist es
die größtmögliche Strafe denn wer
verbrannt wurde konnte im Jenseits nicht
wieder aufstehen der Körper und das
Weiterleben waren dahin
Mitläufern wurde die Nase oder die Ohren
abgeschnitten damit sie so gezeichnet
ihr Leben weiter durchleiden mussten
Tiere und ihr Sohn sind vermutlich aus
hässlichste gefoltert worden um noch
mehr Namen und Verbindungen zu
umstürzten herauszubekommen das wird
schon eine schreckliche Strafe für sich
gewesen sein aber damit war Rams ist der
vierte Sohn von Ramses den dritten nicht
zufrieden und auch iset seine königliche
Mutter wird noch ganz viel negative
Energie in sich gehabt haben oder Mirko
Ramses der vierte berät sich immer
wieder mit seinen hohen Beamten seiner
Mutter und den Priester die Strafe für
Tier muss noch final festgelegt werden
unter der Folter wird klar wie intrigant
sie vorgegangen sind und wie viele am
Hofe entweder geschwiegen oder aktiv an
diesem Komplott gegen seinen Vater
mitgewirkt haben
was auch herauskommt dass der Mord an
seinem Vater die Idee von pentaware
gewesen sein muss die hier hätte den
politischen Umsturz auch noch nach dem
natürlichen Tod des Herrschers umsetzen
können aber pentahua ist ein
ungeduldiger junger Mann nach was fast
noch in Knabe schön und stark war aber
ein Hits Kopf
einerseits denken die zu
gerichtssitzenden daran diesen jungen
komplett auszulöschen andererseits muss
der Mordversuch am Herrscher irgendwie
Außenwirkung und Abschreckung zeigen
Ramses spricht das Urteil
pentawayer soll sich selbst mit dem
Strang Nachrichten danach wird er als
namenloser in ein Ziegenfell gewickelt
und der Gruft übergeben
Warnung und Rätsel gleichermaßen für
alle die da kommen mögen ein Rätsel
bleibt es aber die Gruft scheint
gefunden worden zu sein es gibt eine
Mumie aus dem 12 Jahrhundert vor unserer
Zeit die in der Grabstätte von die ihr
el Bahari bei Theben gefunden wurde bei
der als unbekannter Mann e bezeichneten
Mumie weil man sich schon länger klar
darüber dass es eine besondere Mumie ist
liegt sie doch zwischen Würdenträgern
und Königen das Fernlicht noch
schreiende schmerzverzerrte Gesicht die
würgefalten am Hals und die
Vollständigkeit der inneren Organe
lassen auf eine besondere Behandlung ja
eine Bestrafung des Toten schließen neue
DNA Proben der Mumie ergaben eine 50%ige
Übereinstimmung mit dem Erdmaterial von
Ramses den dritten
das lässt vermuten dass der unbekannte
Mann eh aus der Gruft der verurteilte
Mörder von Ramses und der Sohn der Tier
ist
schlussendlich lässt sich das aber nicht
beweisen weil Tier unauffindbar ist und
so keine DNA-Proben von ihr vorliegen
damals wie heute wurde sie so gut es
geht ausgelöscht
die Handwerker und Stuckateure haben in
diesen Tagen viel zu tun alle
Aufzeichnungen in den neuen schicken
Tempeln den Ergebnissen der
ausschweifenden Bautätigkeit von
Raumsystem dritten müssen von tears
Namen befreit werden nur leere
Kartuschen bleiben übrig es ist als
würde einen namenloser Geist in den
bunten Prozessionen auf den Wänden
mitschreiten schön und namenlos
geheimnisvoll Tier wart nicht mehr
gesehen
aber die blutige Rache von Ramses dem
vierten und seiner königlichen Mutter
iset sind ihr sicher gewiss gewesen man
wird sie wohl lange auf der
schmerzvollen schwebenden Ebene zwischen
dem hier und dem Jenseits gehalten haben
bis ihr schwächer werdendes Licht in den
Tiefen der Zukunft verlosen ist
das klingt jetzt aber alles mal so gar
nicht nach Cold Case wir haben ja das
Turiner Papyrus die Leiche des
ermordeten mit den Verletzungen und den
Hingerichteten Mörder klar das mag sein
mit den uns bekannten Fakten erzählen
wir die Geschichte wie sie sich
wahrscheinlich zugetragen hat aber wer
weiß schon ob das nicht alles ein
Komplott von Ramses Söhnen zusammen mit
iset gewesen ist ziehe und ein Teil des
Hofstaates sind dahinter gekommen und
dann hat man halt die Mitesser
ausgeschaltet ja und der Gewinner
schreibt die Geschichte
damals nicht anders als heute wobei ich
sagen muss dass ich die
Ermittlungsarbeit der Archäologen und
Palio Pathologen wirklich bewundere was
die Leisten ist absolut beeindruckend ja
das ist auch so ein Grund weshalb mich
dieser Fall total fasziniert und immer
wieder beschäftigt dann nutzt du Technik
das 21 jahrhunderts um einen Fall zu
lösen der schon 3000 Jahre alt ist ohne
das CT werden wir ja auch nie dahinter
gekommen Röntgen zeigt das nicht an und
die binden um den Hals der Mumie von
Ramses den dritten konnte man nicht
lösen ohne die Mumie zu zerstören und
was ich auch noch krass finde dass man
den quer Verweis auf dem unbekannten
Mann je nachgegangen ist und da sind
Verbindungen mit dem Papyrus und Ramses
den dritten brachte es ist einfach nur
erstaunliche Posse arbeiten wirklich
wahr auf jeden Fall und es zeigt uns
dass Mord wortwörtlich nicht verjährt
und das mit neuesten Methoden auch bei
einem codecase der so lange zurück liegt
mehrere tausend Jahre noch Spuren zu den
Tätern führen können
boah mein Kopf raucht von all diesen
Kriminalfällen und diesen unglaublichen
Verbrechen aber ich bin froh dass du an
meiner Seite bist lieber Merkurs macht
viel Spaß mit dir zusammen und ich freue
mich auch bald wieder mit euch durch die
Geschichte des True Crime zu streifen
bei eurem Tatort Deutschland Spezial
Liebe Natalie das Kompliment gebe ich
sehr gern zurück und ich sage vielen
Dank an euch da draußen euer Mirko und
eure Natalie
den Fall Ramses erzählen wir mit
Artikeln aus der Welt dem
Wissenschaftsmagazin cynex Wikipedia und
von Archäologie online inspiriert wurden
wir auch von der ZDF-Dokumentation
Verschwörung im Haare
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haier Produktion Marvin schwarz